wake up in the morning sleaving for
breakfast so
that
morninging
is
o
11 them
out
and I walk and I
talk and I
pray
until I found
my i
never never i never i never i never
never never
never B ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne
ne
andai
andai and I
pray I found my Lord i will never i
never i will
never
never never never never never
k
hejachaeme
laerta unabana sera
unas una
y un sombrero va
corriendo muchacho que temprano llegas
hoy historias de amor en el barrio mío
dóe vivo yo dóe vivo yo historias de
amor con otro sentido de vivo yo dóe
vivo yo hay un tipo en el balcón un tipo
de afuera hay un tipo
balc hay un tipo en el
balcón muchacha hay un tipo en el balcón
ábreme la puerta desde el fondo viene un
ruido y un beso para respirar el
televisor se y el espejo que
responde muchacho cómo te fue hoy
historias de amor en el barrio mío de
vivo yo de vivo yo historias de amor con
otro sentido dóe vivo yo dóe vivo yo hay
un tipo en el balc un tipo deuera ha TI
ha un tipo
balcacha ha un tipo en el
balcón
Alito hay un tipo en el balcón
un tipo deuera ha un tipo en Barc un
tipo en la casa Rita un negrito seó a
ese nadie lo conoce pero ella lo invitó
sus amigas la protegen y protegen el
portón y si llega su marido oye se va
por el balcón hay un
tipo hay un tipo ah hay un
tipo hay un tipo hay un tipo ah hay un
tipo eh hay un tipo ha un
tipo
no temp
que como Jardim temp que fado al como
Jardim onde Flores dan
ladoores
lado aguentarão pobrezinas as Frias
naturezaxão não é
certeza o F como que
inventiradoa vida FO para
F como
queent
na Mesa dos sentimentos o coração
éado
rolaitras queúmer
que o dois
TR mes verdade o quatro c
s
felicid n Se sa por ela vho
cantarrir portas al Agora dan
fado é como um jogo que Deus inventou
inspirado se nos p Nesta vida foi para
jogar o fado o fado é como um jogo que
Deus inventou inspirado se nosc Nesta
vida foi para jogar o F se nos na vida
foi paraogar o F se nosc Nesta vida foi
para cantar o
fado
extravagant
voyage
cœurant chevaux
sauvages un DESC nos
orages trop trop ventre plein
de
à l'instant même désir
idem V reconnu toi et moi
n à feu à déjà
perdant
trop PL trop ventreop plein de
temps
non
pas extrême supplice
descente cœur précipice j'appelle
ardente sur les réf l'amour
s'étrangle trop plus trop vent trop
ressemblant
no
B no
B n
B
sur la map monde à vol
d'oiseaux on s dit on peut gagner gros
qu'on a le ciel dans une goutte
d'au on cherche tous mon
destin la vie s'écoule entre nos
mains la joie la peine are chemin
traverser la vie s billet de train
traverser la vie sans billet de train
sur la
route sur la route
la solitude la
mauvaiseté ça fait rêver la
liberté jeai qu'on ne s'ennuira
pas quand on aura du bien tu
vois et ce bonheur qui nous
traverse pour un simple morceau de pain
si tu as faim prends le mien oui si tu
as faim prends le mien sur la
route sur la
route si c'est pas là
merque tu
vois ça y ressemble
bien
sur la
route sur la
route des fois j'aimerais être un
oiseau pouvoir cracher le plus
haut voir les maisons et les
campagnes est mieux leur tourner le
dos on ira vendre nos sacs de
rose prendra le train du
matin sur tous les mur il aura écit de
la justice par la vengeance de la
justice la
vengeance
1 2 3 1 2 3 il y a les playby de
profession habillé par Cardin et chaussé
pas Carville Pipou
pipououou W W qui roule en Ferrari à la
plage comme à la ville qui vont chez
quartier comme ils vont chez
fauchonou croyez-vous que je sois jaloux
Shiba pas du tout Shiba pas du tout pom
c moi j'ai un piège à fille un piège
tabou un joujou extra qui fait craque
bom u les filles en tomb à mes genoux
les filles en tombent en tombe à mes
genou
P pom
C j'ai pas peur des petits minets qui
mangent le ronr oh drugstor miam Mia m
Mia miam miam Mia qui travaill tout
comme les cassors ni avec leurs mains ni
avec leurs pieds miam Mia Mia Mia m Mia
Mia croyez-vous que je sois
jaloux pas du tout pas du
touti j'ai un piège à fille tou un jouou
extra qui fait c les fillesb genou les
filles en tombe en tombe
mes je c pas les les super les béb au
d'athlè
au
Pr
que je sois
jaloux pas du tout pas du
tout moi j'ai un piège à fille un piège
tabou un joujou extra qui fait com les
fill en tomb à mes genou les filles en
tomb en tombe à mes
gen il a lesog les fousux qui disent et
ceux qui savent par
BL par au de cheztherine qui se Mar à
madele
BL croyez-vous que je sois
JAL pas du
tout
tout j'ai un piège à F un piège
touou
fait
lesill fill en tombe les filles en tomb
à mes genou les filles en tombent les
filles en tomb à M genou les fill on Tom
on tombe à mes
genou voilà les
palétuviers
I'm standing at the
crossros there are many roads to
take I stand here so
silently i've got fear of a
mistake
one Road leads to
paradise one Road leads to
pain one Road lead to
freedom they all look the
same
well I've travel many
roads and not all of them were
good the foolish ones t more to
me than the Wise ones
could one Road leads to
sacrifice one Road leads to
shame one Road le to
freedom they all look the
same
so as if by doing
nothing I might find my way
out
Paradise one Road leads to
pain one Road leads to
freedom but I
swear they all look the
same there
r i never
travel there
turns I did
not so many
misies I could not
unravel leaving
you was my only
mist leaving
you
so I'm standing at the
crossroads I'm imprisoned by
my as if by doing
nothing I might find my way
out one r lees to
paradise
one r leaves to
pain and one ro lead to
freedom but I
swear they all look the
same and
there I never
travel and the
turns
I did not
take and the
mysteries I could not
unravel leaving
you my only
mistake I'll le in
you
Valen Powell monsieur Valen
po
oi la BAR da goșto la BA la LAI la te
queimou
lai laa te matou la la te matou de tanto
amor la la la te encostou la oi laa te
queimou lav oi lavara te matou lav e te
matou de tanto amor
la o teu nome é M é quem te quer quer
perder o coração Rosa ardente baarina da
ilusão Mata gente Mata de pxão
lavareda Fogo que parece amor tua dança
é a Chama de uma
Flor rosaardente bailarina da ilusão
Mata a gente Mata de
paixão oi lavareta
tecostou
la
teou la
matou
amcou
Laou t
am
laouá o te nome é quem te quer quer
perder o coração Rosa ardente vaiar n
ilusão Mata a gente Mata de paixão la
pareda o teu nome é mulher quem te quer
quer perder o coração Rosa ardente vai
lá de N ilusão Mata a gente Mata de
paixão oi labareta te
encostou labareta
la
am
ઓલાપરે દજીગોષત laલાઈ
લાલા la te que la la te matou la
la
lac
la matou de tanto
amor te matou de to
amor
monsieur ben Powell bienvenue à Paris
c'est un honneur pour nous de vous
recevoir c'est une plaisir pour moi
merci bon séjour en France et bravo pour
votre musique on applaudit très très
fort
mal